[Music]
welcome back to off the record hey about
whatever we want
yes i think we do on
yo patreon has been [ __ ] crazy man
it's been way more fun but here we're a
little more careful boys that's why it's
really good it's well named i know right
off the record
regular average here
yeah
we do have two things now we got youtube
and you know with youtube
there's uh we're careful boys
patreon we go a little bit harder it's
because they pay you more
it's just for that content no we can't
get um
we can't we can't get like d monetized
and [ __ ] on patreon we could say well
careful here we can't even tell you why
yeah no tell them
it's just like you know like our old
content that jk used to make was pretty
[ __ ] crazy yeah
how long was it since like you've been
here it's like maybe 10 years no no no
no no 10 years when's the last time i
did jk news here oh that's that was a
long [ __ ] time ago at least five at
least five yeah no no you want to be
careful yeah it's youtube though now
man yeah
but that's the thing where like before
we used to go pretty hard on content and
i think over the years just like youtube
getting more commercialized and
algorithm and then the culture of things
we just got to get safer and safer
instance you don't want to get canceled
i don't okay i really don't want to get
caught is that true if you cuss in like
the first 10 minutes of a youtube video
it's like less likely to be monetized i
don't think they care that much about
cussing
i don't even know
so what do they care about and who's
watching these videos by the way i think
when we upload content on youtube i
think we toggle it to say that it's not
appropriate for children um
we should turn that off we also say we
we don't make it for kids which is
that's what it is not necessarily not
appropriate but like we're not making
the content for children doesn't that
also mean it won't get as many views
yeah we should make this but it also
means that if it like doesn't like
possibly children or whatever
puppets yeah but like
but still keep the rawness of jk that
would be great
yeah she's like a puppy that's a lot
though
dude it'd be like the gorillas right
it's like instead of being like an
actual band you could just be like
cartoon monkeys then we could say
anything gorillas
oh it's just a [ __ ] cartoon it's way
more cute right that's like south park
they get away with way crazier [ __ ] yeah
south park family got all them they can
do stuff because it's like
it's not it's not a paywall it's a
two-dimensional they're also not on
youtube
but they're on like prime time almost
yeah but comedy central also not on
youtube
with those guys i think once you have
that legacy and you're worked into the
studio system the studios lawyers also
got your back
you know when you're on youtube you're
you're a constant auditioning process we
need lawyers dude that's why you need a
lawyer
there's people at youtube who sit there
and they have a different color hair
than i do
probably purple maybe perhaps not it's
definitely not organic what about blue
could be could be teal
but red
they they feel like their opinions need
to affect your video as well and that's
because the process is different i think
it's like this like youtuber and youtube
it's like youtuber right i'm youtube
okay let me see how you're going to [ __ ]
up today
right but then comedy central south park
because i'm like hey buddy let's go make
money together
that's why i think it's true i like that
i don't need you [ __ ] i don't need you
you'll be replaced tomorrow literally i
already forgot you i don't care if you
made millions of dollars for us i don't
care how many subscribers you got
someone will replace you yeah there will
be a kid chat
that could generate more [ __ ] views
and more ad sales than you tomorrow is
more successful
what if we have a segment where we just
start opening up like toys and then just
unbox it
that way we kill two birds in one stone
we get the adults and we get the kids
combined while we talk [ __ ] a little bit
of both we need to replace ourselves
right now if we are puppets do you think
we can go back to 2016 jk news
conversations dude south park does it
they're they're animated as [ __ ] as
puppets
yeah they're right well they're not real
to start right so they're like already
in the public character puppets we can
say the [ __ ] that we can't say as
characters as humans as long as like
there's that there's that the lawyer
wall between you and the puppet cause
then as long
cause somebody can cancel the puppet but
they can't they can't cancel their hands
or the mouth that cause you know what i
noticed snl
used to make political commentary and
all this stuff and now they're just like
super safe
well they just do the one political
commentary yeah they still do it it's
just only one scientist just do the ones
it's all trump stuff or what maybe
the whole time even when he's not in
office they're still doing trump [ __ ]
yeah
damn he's popular he's very popular
everybody likes doing a trump kim
kardashian like the new snl host is she
what really like host host think so not
a guess i thought she just did a guest
thing
that's crazy if she becomes a cast
that'd be insane can you imagine the
kardashians as the cast of snl what if
she becomes lauren michaels well they
got to find something to do because i
guess their shows ending
i saw this i was on like
i was on quora yesterday and i was just
like looking at [ __ ] and there was
somebody who like clearly hates the
kardashians and they're like well i
wonder what those kardashians are going
to do now to their shows and they hope
they didn't spend all their money
and i'm like bro you have literally no
idea about them they make they're some
of them are billionaires bro they can't
[ __ ] it up if they tried like multiple
sisters this person like clearly just
hates them and they're like dunking on
them like um like being like um well you
know how their spending habits are and
i'm like bro you have no [ __ ] idea
how much money they have
they're making habits are out of this
world they're making you happy they
think they made money from their e-show
like that's probably their smallest
check like if you know how this [ __ ]
works that's just their marketing made
money on her on her wedding with that
one basketball player
dude
you think they're getting millions an
episode for e no [ __ ] way bro there's
no way they're gonna they're gonna make
more than [ __ ] friends which was the
highest point
they did have 30 seasons though didn't
they oh yeah some like ridiculous
amounts yeah but better than youtube
yeah
faster they got their makeup
going in there
they made a career out of actually
getting people addicted to hating them
they're geniuses yeah they're [ __ ]
geniuses
was it was it making a career off that
or was it like a sex tape first
the sex game got attention
yeah but you don't stay relevant with
just a sex tape strong launch no yeah
but there's lots of people with sex
tapes they don't all crush it like that
and you can't give head that bad and and
like you know the rage dick then yeah it
was rages
it was him ray j is a career starter
yeah he is he kind of is but his
headphones aren't doing that good ray
kons yeah i had no i thought wait rages
buying raycon no that's his that's his
headphones oh that's not acorn it works
good they weren't no they combined they
linked up they looked like you had yeah
yeah dude that's the hottest [ __ ]
apparently they're very good they're
good but i don't think they're crushing
it
but i feel like kim is also a biter
because the original is paris yes paris
hilton did she
do a sex tape too or no she just did it
better well she did one i don't think
she knew that she was being filmed oh
really i don't think she knew or is that
just really good actually so kim didn't
know that kim knew kim knew she's been
filming
looking at the camera it was like like
it looked like [ __ ] nightmares the
footage for uh you may yeah for research
purposes i mean if i was hosting not to
criticize you i think we've already been
up you know we we'd be halfway through
it it's just like no no no no no the
parasite was actually uh
but no that was a very popular sex tape
google pair wait which one are we
looking for pears for skim
who had the better ones
kimberly
compilation video the paris hilton one
wasn't that at night kim kardashian's
remember the night vision dude it was
the night vision yeah hella night vision
that was the theme it was like they're
getting bit lost
afghanistan wait what was that
half of the paris video was like in the
dark and all you just see is the sparkle
in her eye like going up and down they
should have called it something else
something with the shtick it looked like
a [ __ ] zombie like [ __ ] that was
weird yeah
i somehow i somehow went into this
rabbit hole that says what will kim
kardashian tell her kids about her sex
tape
i don't know if that's an article worth
reading that's funny but i am curious
man yeah yeah yeah it'll probably be a
sex positive accomplishment billionaire
now yeah
it's a new generation should be on a
carnival ride that she owns
breaking the news
on a ferris wheel yeah what the [ __ ]
give me a break kisses kim kardashian
i'm fascinated by her i used to [ __ ]
not like her i want her that's what this
or how many kids she has how many kids
does she have
just with kanye's just one right one is
it one crazy is it like wait do you
think she has like five she had like
three
north west
north
is it four because there's the compass
has four no but his last name is west
she north south east west she needs
three more i don't know so she's trying
to complete it she should is that over
right why would you not you know aren't
they it's a great yeah they wait they're
over yeah they're they're
not they're split
this is the most i've talked about kim
kardashian a long time since sex tape
today's video is brought to you by feels
cbd isn't what you feel it's about what
you do not feel like stress anxiety and
all the things that boggle down your
brain and you just gotta relax and you
know this is something that i've been
using for quite some time now and i
really like because i've been on the
road for like the past three months
a lot of different time zones a lot of
different sleep patterns and that's
really been getting to me and i was like
oh now i remember why i travel with the
fields it's super easy
you know when you're not in your routine
the bedtime rituals don't really happen
and um i think that affects my kind of
sleep usually so i'm not like sleeping
at a good hour but now what i can do is
go
through with my travel fields and then i
can just relax
and have my whole system back like when
i'm back here and i go to sleep and it
feels really nice
yeah if
sleeplessness anxiety or stress or even
bodily pain is something that troubles
you
feels this is something that can help
with that and they also got a hotline
that you can call if you're like hey how
am i am i supposed to take the whole
bottle they might go oh wait wait wait
wait is this your first time maybe put a
couple of drops helps you relax and you
have someone that can help you walk you
through the whole thing and once you
figure out your regular dosage then you
can also sign up for the monthly
subscription so that you don't have to
worry about it every month they'll send
you a bottle or two or however many you
put down delivery baby so you can become
a member today by going to feels.com
off the record to get 50 off plus free
shipping and that's feels f e a l s dot
com slash off the record to get 50 off
plus free shipping that's a lot of money
oh yeah 50
but by the way this does say
that in terms of the history of her sex
tape they were dating o3 the the tape
was leaked four years later against her
uh you know will obviously she wanted to
remain private so it led to a lawsuit to
vivid entertainment which means that uh
there was a settlement that she ended up
getting five million dollars for five
million in your [ __ ] first leak sex
tape as long as you [ __ ] with a
celebrity maybe you can get like
settlement money off top so like she
knew she was talking
she was a nobody when it leaked no one
knew her backup dancer and ray j is the
nobody too when it leaked oh that's true
he did have a fire song was it monica's
brother
no but it was monica's brother right
yeah it's not like it's not like usher
wait was it monica or was it what's her
name
randy randy's brother was it brandy's
brother yeah brandy's brother that's
what i knew him as yeah one of them ray
j is brandy's brother i didn't know that
we should i didn't know that oh that's
what i knew of man was he on the show
sure has seen his dick
brandy
as a child yeah as a kid like she's
gonna she's god my brother what's your
point
yeah
you think randy saw it for sure she did
unless unless he was like [ __ ] i don't
want to win
back when like social media was like you
didn't have as much content on do you
think you think brandy's a computer like
i should just see it once
this should be a whole segment of dudes
talking about [ __ ] hollywood gossip
[ __ ] yeah
because we really don't obviously have
the inside just getting it all wrong
the youngest one is a billionaire
she got the tequila company the makeup
products and all that [ __ ] 805. or she's
close to she's close to being a
billionaire 808 thank you it was crazy
808 huh yeah no it's 805 808 is [ __ ]
liquor i mean uh uh is the hawaiian area
code no no there's a 805 beer i think
808 heart breaks
that's her 805 beer no no no oh that
that's the beer and then she just did a
tequila called called eight away numbers
[ __ ] by googling proving joe's point
that guy's talking about celebrity
gossip is incredible he's [ __ ]
most of the eight one eight eight one
eight oh that makes sense because she's
from glendale yeah she's for the valley
oh no that makes sense 808 from hawaii
back to this 5 million settlement though
if i had a leaked sex tape and i could
get at least 500 000 i might leak it
that's pretty good maybe 50 000. what
about what about paris how much does she
get out of it
then just looking up the settlement for
that um paris are you sexy it's hot now
because you got everyone on only fans
and like it's it's kind of diluted don't
want it yeah yeah
cause i'm sure it's not that crazy
but but it depends on the person like
let's say like um someone's squeaky
clean like julia roberts had a text tape
wow i'm watching it yeah it'd be like
whoa what are you doing did you guys
watch the colin farrell one anybody yes
what is that
anybody
no oh my god colin farrell yeah dude
yeah bro irish accent and all wait was
it in the movie alexander like nah it
was a real life sex tape dog really you
guys you guys are all you're not good
for all what are you guys doing all day
i don't search for the men we're looking
at sex stuff i don't i don't look at no
just popular celebrities almost
celebrity feed
one is have you guys heard of chloe
who's that there's a movie that she's in
called the brown bunny with this guy
named vincent gallo who's like a [ __ ]
whackass director
and he he convinced her to suck his dick
in this movie no way he's in the movie
no he's the director of the movie and
he's the star of the movie with her and
she's like playing his love interest and
he convinced her to suck his dick in the
movie and she actually blew him on
camera and like he like [ __ ] like
unloads in her mouth no way
is this a long time ago or is this this
is like yeah a long time ago like i
can't believe that they're that they did
that in a movie they did in a movie so
the fact that he was the director was
like i think we need you to suck my dick
for your character's arc that's my [ __ ]
for your arc yeah
yeah what a [ __ ] that's [ __ ] crazy
continue directing because you have the
whole day to direct but now you know
that you just came into like your
actress's mouth that's what the 80s fall
asleep and call it a day
like that that's terrible that's [ __ ]
up
i don't know why i'm providing a face to
the name for your imaginations so [ __ ]
up why is that a poor hub no it's imdb
okay so yeah he
broke he busts in her mouth and he's
like hey check the gate yeah check the
gate oh back to one got to do it
again oh but it still says that if i
can't so at the time unfortunately
take a break everyone
at the time unfortunately her
representation they all dropped her oh
they dropped her for that kind of got
cycled out this movie comes out at like
a festival or whatever nobody really
cares did they drop her because she gave
head on because she did that oh yeah
because she didn't want her well it's
not the director's fault exactly please
set that guy on fire bro exactly so
director guy yeah what other movie did
he do i mean bro you've never heard of
them in your life because all of them
ends up porn that's what
every scene has that i've heard of him
but you've seen his work all these
unpublished movies you know
it's like you're playing my mother it's
important for your art to blow me
as well that's also going to be your
part of your heart yeah
yeah oh my god vincent gallo dude yeah
dude guy's a legend but come back um so
then but then she kind of you know
slowly worked her way back in to
hollywood and she's like in stuff again
she's like she's awesome
oh my god that's [ __ ] mind-blowing
yeah because i know that like
because i know like european films or
whatever there's like ones where there's
like straight-up
sex scenes that they're like yeah
there's intercourse in some of them yeah
yeah but it's different it's artsy yeah
you know it's acceptable yeah i think
it's a little bit different when they're
when you're a director like like imagine
in the if [ __ ] mel gibson in
braveheart was like in the middle of his
speech and he told one of the dudes to
blow him while he's talk doing his work
then he's also the director so the best
thing about the in the brown bunny right
so the chick's blowing him but he keeps
on cutting up to his own face oh
that's wild the best dude yeah this
guy's a psychopath
it's definitely not not this is your
favorite movie it's a great movie this
this guy should be in a good movie i've
never watched the movie
okay you know that's like that's like
when uh uh
clint eastwood he made the movie called
the mule and he was like you know what
this movie needs we need to have a
threesome with me in it
he had a threesome yeah that's what
everyone was talking about
yeah that was the whole hype about it
well did they actually [ __ ]
probably he's not in his condition bowls
all over his body
like old man moles and [ __ ]
yeah he for sure was but the fact that
like you need a threesome scene why does
clint eastwood need to be in a threesome
and how is this important for his
character's arc
it's clint eastwood because sex cells
you [ __ ] idiot
but now it's clint eastwood yeah dear
damn right he's 98 years old bro
i see that guy [ __ ] that's crazy
that's crazy
colin farrell yes
irish accents i'm in bro was he a sex
traveler going to thailand or some [ __ ]
i think he was like a mule for drugs in
them i think that's the premise of the
movie damn
or i could be completely wrong who knows
and who cares
do you think the director just dropped
it on her like oh you know what would
make this scene dope is if you suck my
dick or do you think it was in the
script it was i think it was in the
description
with pence yeah yeah yeah exactly
because lawrence is the most legit actor
in here right what if someone threw that
on you in the middle of you didn't even
know this and they're like
all right i think to make this better
you need to suck some dick you had to do
that last year right yeah yeah yeah it
was great
[ __ ] you know
you go there i'm a trooper yeah i'm an
actor man yeah whatever gets you scene
like all right so you're in walking dead
there's a scene you're the governor's
right hand man
you know what that is you've got nothing
right
right hand man right hand man okay i use
my left though for him i'm walking dead
you're on
the director says to make this
believable
it's post-apocalyptic world it's the
only way you could calm him down
it's to suck his dick to give him a
release yeah sweet release
what would you do like in that moment if
it calls for it in the story yeah you
know and it pushes the story forward
okay and he's really convincing in it
like in his explanation so yeah it makes
sense because it's motivated if it's
motivated i'm like okay you know what
like if this pushes this character to
like you know
wreak havoc um
continually throughout the the season
then i guess maybe i will you know so in
the you're not thinking
you just want me to suck your dick i'm
not going to suck his dick man
you guys have cgi for this
come on man
i will you know i'd probably talk to the
director a little bit it'd be like come
on dude do i have to release like
important is it for me to suck this
guy's dick
that's the real question yeah because
that's what i'm thinking is like
everyone will push back oh but i want to
hear that yeah like
i want to hear the explanation and then
like
no i'm not gonna do it like even in
horror movies when a guy gets killed
they like don't they like pan away
sometimes they just show it like yeah
right after they kill him they put a
dick in his mouth
in the dick yeah but it's like carved
exactly like his dick but it's like you
know still con so so for this four story
purposes
if it really pushes the story forward i
will pretend to suck the dick that's
what most people do yeah that's what
that's what all guys are saying so why
did in this movie she actually sucked
this dick without fighting wanted oh why
does she suck he's very convinced
because she's a woman
she feels probably like [ __ ] like i feel
like i need to do this like there's like
some like power there's some power this
was like 2 000 and this is back in the
day right so like anything the director
says she's going to be like oh god
damn
it sucks i'm surprised this dude wasn't
[ __ ] canceled yet
we should cancel them
like over there
over where it wasn't a european movie no
no because i'm just saying european
movies because i've seen sex stuff in
the european movies but i don't know if
this is american european
it was definitely a european movie was
it yeah this cat's like from definitely
a
not a limey but he's i don't know he's a
crowd i don't know this guy's sketchy
crowd means german right
oh okay no can't be trusted this guy i
can't remember that i don't remember
what he is
you